[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue sur TV 78 pour le 7
8 c'est votre émission pour bien
démarrer la soirée dans les Yvelines
installez-vous confortablement on va
dérouler le programme tout de suite de
ce mardi 16 mai
design de Lucas Giovanni morira a été
réalisé le week-end dernier pour
célébrer le futur Eco quartier de la
ville retour dans le 7 8
et il y aura comme d'habitude le point
sur les informations du jour ce sera
avec vous à Céline Charles bonsoir
bonsoir de la rédaction de tv78 on va
reparler notamment de ce sommet tchuss
France qui s'est tenu hier au château de
Versailles vous étiez sur place avec
Nicolas dandry et on revient aussi avec
vous sur le déplacement déplacement
récent de la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale dans les Yvelines elle est
aussi députée vinoise
s'est déplacé à la maison de l'Oseraie
aux Mureaux vendredi dernier elle a pu
échanger pas mal avec les jeunes et les
adultes qui sont engagés dans la commune
et on en reparlera tout à l'heure les
invités du 7 8 également avec nous en
plateau Laurent masaury bonsoir bonsoir
vice-président de 50 ans divine je le
disais délégué au sport également aux
Jeux Olympiques j moins 437 désormais
avant le lancement des jeux de paris
2024 on rappelle qu'à 50 ans en ligne il
y a quatre sites des JO qui sont
implantés et notamment la colline
d'Élancourt dont on parle ce soir on va
faire le point sur l'avancée des travaux
ce qui est prévu aussi pour l'avenir de
cette colline après les Jeux Olympiques
ça se rapproche de plus plus
l'engouement monte à 50 ans en Yvelines
alors nous l'engouement monte et il a
toujours monté depuis quasiment que nous
savons que nous avons été retenus ont
été la même monté en 2012 avec la
précédente candidature et puis on sera
dans le timing et on en parlera dans un
instant l'engouement monte aussi le
ramadan autour d'un autre nom est-ce que
Victor web benyama ça vous dit quelque
chose si vous suivez l'actualité
on est toujours fier d'avoir des alors
mon collègue ici présent m'expliquait
que c'est encore avant les poussins
c'est bien ça donc savoir qu'il a
commencé chez nous c'est un peu quand
même Mbappé à Bondy on en est très très
fier c'est la pépite du basket français
elle connaîtra cette nuit cette pépites
Victor one bagnat l'équipe NBA qui aura
le premier choix pour la draft 2023
c'est à dire la franchise qui aura le
plus de chance de le recruter en vue de
la saison prochaine l'occasion de
rappeler que Victor et yvelinois je le
disais il a commencé du côté de
l'Entente Le Chesnay Versailles c'est un
patrimoine niblinois à défendre même si
il a effectué ses premières toutes
premières années avant de filer du côté
des Hauts-de-Seine dans le 92 à Nanterre
Philippe
le président de l'Entente Le Chesnay
Versailles et ce que vous aussi vous
avez succombé à cette fièvre Victor
wendyama qui s'étendrait quand même de
la France même des États-Unis l'autre de
l'autre côté de la santé effectivement
on parle de plus qu'une fièvre en
réalité mon Victor qui a démarré chez
nous tout petit à bien progresser il a
beaucoup travaillé avec le club de
Nanterre qu'il faut féliciter puisque
c'est dans ce club professionnel qui a
vraiment appris le basket il avait des
qualités innées à la fois en taille
puisque c'est un très grand gabarit déjà
et puis par ailleurs il a une mobilité
exceptionnelle d'un meneur de jeu donc
en réalité quand on fait 2m21 et puis
que à seulement 19 ans seulement 19 ans
et qu'on a une mobilité de de bonheur
c'est c'est plus exceptionnel c'est même
pas une pépite je dirais c'est un
prodige en réalité il y a peu de
d'athlètes français qui ont atteint ce
niveau bon vous parliez de Mbappe on
peut parler de quelques sportifs de
SPORTCO mais pas à ce niveau là
l'occasion d'en dire un peu plus tout à
l'heure est-ce que vous allez suivre
vous la loterie cette nuit
avec les play-offs donc je vais suivre
effectivement la draft et on en parle
tout à l'heure dans le 7 8 également ce
soir zoom sur la première journée du
développement durable pour les échos
délégués des Yvelines retour également
sur un défilé de mode 100 % et
co-responsable il s'est tenu dimanche à
Versailles puis comme chaque mardi les
insolites de Véronique Iturbide ces
informations originales qui vous ont
peut-être échappé dans l'actualité
vinoise sous cela bien sûr après avoir
regardé les prévisions météo de demain
[Musique]
on a des conditions similaires à celle
d'aujourd'hui la matinée de mercredi
sera ensoleillée dans les Yvelines
comptez 10 degrés dans toute la moitié
est du département 9 degrés dans le
secteur de Houdan l'après-midi le ciel
devrait se couvrir mais les températures
remontent il fera à 16 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie ou dans les Rambouillet
15 degrés dans le secteur de Versailles
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et demain nous
fêterons les Pascal Le Point présent sur
l'actualité du jour dans les Yvelines
et on commence avec cette information
révélée cet après-midi Céline du nouveau
dans l'affaire Samuel Paty 14 personnes
sont renvoyées en procès oui alors pour
rappel le professeur
d'histoire-géographie avait été
poignardée puis décapité par un
islamiste radicalisé à la sortie de son
collège de Conflans-Sainte-Honorine le
16 octobre 2020 l'assassinat avait été
perpétrée par un seul assaillant abdulak
Enzo Rohff abattu dans la foulée par la
police mais il est juste d'instructions
anti-terroriste ont ordonné ce mardi le
jugement de 14 autres personnes parmi
elles on retrouve deux amis de la seyant
et six autres adultes qui seront jugés
pour association de malfaiteurs
terroristes criminels adolescents
devront également comparaître devant le
tribunal des enfants notamment la
collégienne qui avait enclenché
l'affaire en montant sur la teneur du
cours du professeur ces informations du
jour avec cet événement que vous avez
suivi hier avec Nicolas dandry également
sur tv68 et sur nos réseaux sociaux 200
investisseurs internationaux et
rendez-vous au château de Versailles à
l'occasion du sixième Sommet tous France
tout à fait Grégory et il venait
notamment échanger avec le président
Emmanuel Macron on l'a vu parmi les
dirigeants Elon Musk PDG de Tesla
Twitter et SpaceX il a fait son
apparition au château après avoir été
reçu à l'Élysée à même dit envisager des
investissements significatifs de Tesla
en France mais ce sixième chose France
et surtout 13 milliards d'euros
d'investissement étrangers promis par
une vingtaine d'entreprises comme Ikea
Nokia ou encore Pfizer des fonds qui
permettront notamment la création de
8000 emplois écoutés
nous investissons 140 millions d'euros
en France jusqu'en 2025 et cela
représente 8000 points de charge dans
plusieurs villes de plusieurs régions de
France donc nous sommes alignés sur les
objectifs du gouvernement d'installer
400 000 points de charges d'ici à 2030
nous collaborons avec des entreprises
françaises pour installer nos points de
charge et pour nous aider à la
maintenance des infrastructures et nous
avons aussi une équipe de 49 personnes
qui sont basées dans plusieurs parties
du pays premier message la France est
donc pour la quatrième fois consécutive
la nation la plus attractive et nous
comptons bien rester en tête du podium
dans cette sixième édition de tchuss
France on voit se dessiner les filières
industrielles du 21e siècle avec des
points forts qui seront les points forts
industriels de la France dans les
décennies qui viennent nous voulons
maintenant accélérer en utilisant la
transformation climatique et le
changement climatique comme levier de
décarbonation et de réinvestissement en
France et en marge de l'événement en
recours contrôle et drone déployés pour
la sécurité du sommet avait été déposé
par un élu d'opposition et un habitant
de Versailles un recours qui a été
rejeté le jour même par les juges des
réfugrés du tribunal administratif de
Versailles le dispositif de drone avait
notamment été mise en place pour la
manifestation contre la réforme des
retraites qui a eu lieu juste avant
l'événement devant le château elle a
réuni près de 200 personnes une décision
du tribunal administratif de Versailles
qui concerne le Conseil départemental
des Yvelines le sujet du projet
déviation de la route la route
départementale 154 oui alors le projet
de déviation de la route 154 et
souhaitée par le Conseil départemental
depuis de nombreuses années il a pour
but de créer une voie nouvelle de
contournement de 6 km à travers le bois
de Vernouillet pour tout simplement des
engorger la traversée des centres villes
de Vernouillet Verneuil-sur-Seine et
dechapper du trafic de transit c'est un
projet largement contesté par les élus
et habitants des villes concernées et
une décision de justice tant à les
encourager le tribunal de Versailles à
condamné le Conseil départemental à
restituer son terrain à une habitante de
Chappée expropriée depuis 2014 pour la
réalisation de la future déviation une
avancée pour les opposants au projet qui
voient cette décision comme un premier
pas vers le blocage définitif le sport
est un jeu niveau qui va faire ses
débuts à Roland-Garros le tournoi du
Grand Chelem se déroule du 28 mai au 11
juin Porte d'Auteuil à Paris et Antoine
guibaudeau sera de la si le joueur de 18
ans formé au Comité des Yvelines de
Feucherolles bénéficient de la part de
la Fédération Française de Tennis d'une
wild card c'est à dire d'une invitation
pour les tours de qualification il
faudrait il faudra donc franchir ses
qualifications dès la semaine prochaine
pour accéder au grand tableau de
l'événement Antoine guibaudeau a déjà
participé à Roland-Garros junior mais
c'est une première chez les grands sur
ces images maintenant il a 18 ans
actuellement antoine guibaudon va lui
souhaiter bonne chance effectivement
pour ce tour de qualification on parle
ensuite d'une hyblinoise en finale d'un
concours mondial concours organisé par
L'Oréal tout à fait souvenez-vous
Grégory d'ailleurs nous l'avions reçu
sur notre plateau en avril dernier Marie
landrevy originaire de Poissy elle est
représentée la France en demi-finale du
concours mondial d'innovation L'Oréal un
concours qui met en compétition des
candidats du monde entier pour proposer
des innovations dans le secteur de la
beauté Marie landrevy et son équipe ont
remporté 7 demi-finale grâce à leur
proposition une technologie qui permet
de pouvoir tester des produits sur un
site e-commerce à partir une photo
prochaine étape maintenant la finale
elle aura la chance de pitcher son
projet le vendredi 16 juin prochain au
salon vivatech à Paris au total 10
équipes sont qualifiées pour la finale
sur plus de 15000 au départ petite
question à nos invités
en cours notamment vivre dans le adjoint
il y a un cinéma qui a planté
du cinéma donc oui je suis très fan de
cinéma évidemment
je suis un fan mais bon pour autant il
n'y a pas que ça il y a le basket aussi
vous savez ce qui s'ouvre ce soir en
tout cas en matière de cinéma comment le
Festival de Cannes
international et justement on termine
ces infos du jour avec l'ouverture du
Festival de Cannes qui a quand même
aussi des liens avec les Yvelines
édition lors de la cérémonie d'ouverture
c'est le film Jeanne du Barry de Maïwenn
qui sera projeté et sur la Croisette on
retrouve l'envoyée spéciale de radio
sensation Corentin Alonzo Corentin c'est
un peu les Yvelines qui sont à l'honneur
avec ce film
en effet Céline puisque ce film présenté
hors compétition a notamment été tourné
en grande partie avec Versailles le
château de Versailles par exemple
accueilli le tournage pendant ces jours
de fermeture au public Jeanne Dubarry
c'est un film historique réalisé par
Maïwenn dans lequel elle incarne la
maîtresse du roi Louis XV jouer par
Johnny Depp On en regarde un extrait
tout de suite
[Musique]
la comtesse jade du Barry
surtout
le regardez pas le roi dans les yeux ce
serait perçu par la cour comme une
invitation
à quoi à la baguette
Jeanne Dubarry de Maïwenn qui a été
également soutenu par la Région
Île-de-France à hauteur de 595000 euros
et pas besoin d'être à Cannes pour voir
ce film puisqu'il sort en salle partout
en France
et merci Corentin Alonso en tout cas
pendant ces 10 jours rendez-vous sur
Radio sensation et TV 78 pour vivre le
Festival de Cannes à travers nos
reportages nos interviews et nos
émissions spéciales merci à Céline pour
toutes ces informations et si vous aussi
près de chez vous comme d'habitude vous
êtes témoin d'une actualité qui vous
fait réagir n'hésitez pas à la partager
sur les réseaux sociaux en utilisant le
hashtag 7 8 news
[Musique]
et on parle à présent au de ce sujet
d'envergure pour le territoire des
Yvelines et aussi celui de 50 ans en
Yvelines et Jeux Olympiques qui arrivent
tous prochainement un peu plus d'un an
désormais avant cette échéance olympique
4 sites des JO qui sont implantés sur le
territoire de 50 ans en Yvelines on va
faire le point avec vous le remasouris
sur les travaux l'avancée des travaux
sur la colline d'Élancourt voir aussi
quel projet sera donné par la suite à ce
site pour donc son avenir et après ces
Jeux olympiques de Paris 2024 des
travaux préparatoires avaient débuté
l'an passé sur la colline on va dire des
travaux qui sont entrés dans le concret
depuis janvier est-ce que ça avance bien
depuis là c'est la réalisation de la
piste olympique qui est en cours du du
côté de la colline il y a deux phases
pour faire simple il y a la phase avant
Jo il y aura une phase très importante
après les JO pour la phase d'héritage
vous en avez parlé tout à l'heure le but
c'est d'ouvrir cette colline au plus
grand nombre ensuite mais j'y reviendrai
et bien la première phase elle est
aujourd'hui quasiment terminée nous
allons enfin le solideo qui l'organisme
qui s'occupe de ces traits de piloter
ces travaux va bientôt remettre les clés
à Paris 2024 là dans quelques jours pour
qu'on les réalise début septembre le
festivalt puisqu'on a la chance d'avoir
sur Saint-Quentin le seul test grandeur
nature qui sera réalisé de
fonctionnement d'un site olympique on va
y tester bien entendu la piste on va y
tester les infrastructures la qualité
des travaux réalisés mais on va y tester
également tout ce qui tourne autour et
qui permet aussi aux épreuves d'avoir
lieu c'est à dire aussi bien la partie
informatique télématique que la sécurité
que les transports que l'arrivée en vélo
etc tout va être testé et ça aura lieu
dans le week-end du 24 septembre
prochain en même temps que l'Open
d'ailleurs de France de golf c'est aussi
une gageur effectivement et le golf en
plus au programme bien sûr olympique de
ces JO on a vu quelques images de
l'entrée du chantier de cette colline on
va peut-être pouvoir voir aussi hein
c'est solideo la solideo qui les a
révélés les premières images du du
parcours on reparle on reprécise que la
seule idée c'est la société de livraison
des ouvrages olympiques là sur la
colline on va avoir une une piste de
premier plan puisque elle sera sur ces
Jeux Olympiques et chose importante elle
sera aussi conservée dans le tracé après
de des après les Jeux Olympiques alors
tout à fait la phase d'héritage elle a
deux parties enfin les travaux liés à
l'héritage en deux parties une partie
ouvert au grand public pour tout le
monde puisse se promener en coexistence
avec les vététistes ce qui est une
gageur parce qu'on sait que parfois ces
sources de conflit entre autres à la
montagne ou les vététistes ont du mal à
coexister avec les piétons là pour le
coup les deux existeront et donc dans le
cas des pistes de VTT vous aurez la
piste noire qui sera directement
hérité de la piste des Jeux Olympiques
et puis on décline un peu comme au ski
des pistes jaunes vertes bleues et
rouges et les pistes noires nous
permettront ensuite de revenir utiliser
ce site éventuellement pour y faire des
championnats de France ou des
championnats du monde au fil des années
qui qui viendront donc vous l'avez dit
pistolympique très prochainement livré
en vue du Test Event qui aura lieu à
l'automne 2023 sur sur cette piste
olympique de la colline à quoi ça va
ressembler très concrètement le test
even ça va être vraiment une répétition
générale avant les Jeux Olympiques alors
c'est une répétition générale avec un
petit peu moins de monde on y attend
entre 3000 et 5000 personnes alors que
nous attendons 12000 personnes pour la
phase vraiment des des deux jours je
rappelle que c'est seulement deux jours
d'épreuve là le Test Event a lieu grosso
modo sur trois jours et on va vraiment
c'était la totalité de tout ce qui
pourra fonctionner et j'espère entre
guillemets qu'on aura des choses qui ne
fonctionneront pas parce que sur les
choses qui ne fonctionneront pas ça nous
permettra au contraire de capitaliser
dessus pour encore améliorer l'accueil à
la fois des sportifs des journalistes
puisque ils seront nombreux à Élancourt
pour ces épreuves mais également et
surtout de tous les tous ceux qui
viendront visiter du coup le territoire
à travers leur présence sur ce site des
Jeux Olympiques même si à l'issue de ce
test event il y a il y aura une
finalisation des travaux des
aménagements en vue des JO ça va
poursuivre jusqu'au printemps 2024
exactement ça se poursuge qu'au
printemps 2024 ensuite on rentre en
phase où on arrête tout intervention sur
le site et surtout ça reprend après les
JO pour une année complète de travaux et
donc au cours juste après les yeux
pardon vous avez parlé de la phase
héritage ma question c'est de savoir
pourquoi c'était important pour ce site
qui était autrefois fermé au public en
l'ouvrait pour des événements il y a eu
des trails il y a eu la revancheur aussi
une épreuve bien sûr cycliste pourquoi
c'est important pour l'agglomération de
pouvoir lui donner un avenir et l'ouvrir
aux habitants la réponse avec les
aimants dans la dans votre question on
avait un site immense le point le plus
haut de France il remonte à son sommet
on voit tout Paris et on voit une grande
partie de la banlieue parisienne et
d'ailleurs aussi bien vers l'ouest toute
la partie verte et aujourd'hui il était
fermé officiellement public beaucoup de
gens s'il faut filer et il y en avait
pas le bénéfice que la population peut
en attendre alors que c'est un site
emblématique pour 50 ans de vie pour
Élancourt et pour l'Île-de-France en
général donc il fallait l'ouvrir et en
cela les Jeux Olympiques ont été comme
pour beaucoup d'autres choses un vrai
vecteur qui va bien au-delà du sport
parce que les JO c'est un peu de sport
mais c'est beaucoup d'aménagement et
beaucoup d'équipements territoriaux et
dans le cas de la colline Delancourt ça
nous a permis en fait d'avancer
quasiment de 30 ans ce qui aurait pris
un nombre incroyable de temps si on
avait voulu réaliser les travaux qui
sont sur place je rappelle que c'est un
des rares sites ou une sera couler aucun
gramme de béton et à l'inverse c'est
probablement le site qui reçoit le plus
de compensation écologique puisque dans
les 12 millions 200000 euros de travaux
plus de 3 millions d'euros sont
consacrés au compensation écologique qui
commence une fois que le site aura été
utilisé par les JO et qui a commencé
déjà aujourd'hui par la suppression des
espèces invasives qui empêchaient une
nidification en particulier de tout ce
des rongeurs et des oiseaux juste après
les Jeux une nouvelle phase
d'aménagement a priori en 2025 la
colline sera ouverte normalement le
train c'est d'ouvrir à la rentrée 2025
septembre octobre 2025 à la fois au
vététiste et à l'ensemble de la
population avec les habitants qui ont
été associés dans une phase de
concertation il y a eu différentes
phases on avait parlé ensemble il me
semble sur ce plateau de la
participation du public par voie
électronique c'était l'an passé comment
ont été associés juste pour revenir sur
cette phase de concertation les 50
chinois dans dans la réalisation de ces
projets alors il y a eu un certain
nombre de réunions publiques j'allais
dire c'est assez traditionnel mais je
pense que là les échanges ont été vif et
passionnés il y a eu également des
réunions faut le savoir en amont je
pense aux associations écologiques
d'Élancourt avec lequel on a beaucoup
travaillé c'était très inquiète au début
et je pense qu'aujourd'hui elles peuvent
voir et constater la qualité des travaux
réalisés encore une fois ils ne sont pas
terminés je pense que vraiment l'effet
waoud un point de vue écologique sera
pour après les JO et lors de ces
différentes réunions il a été tenu
compte des uns des différents retours
qui avaient été faits pour amender le
projet à la marge mais c'est souvent
dans le détail que se situe en fait le
plus grands risques et donc ce sont tous
ces petits détails additionner qui ont
permis de corriger un salon d'idées a
priori quand on travaille sur un plan
c'est pas la même chose que contre un
travail dans la réalité du terrain je
pense aux différents domaines également
il y a des problématiques de proximité
on a un immeuble au pied de la colline
côté lencourt on a deux domaines de
pavillons qui sont à la fois sur plaisir
et également sur la commune des longs
qui sont vraiment en rive avec
l'aménagement il fallait rassurer mais
il va falloir montrer également que les
engagements qu'on a pris que la solideo
a pris on sera capable de les réaliser
pour pouvoir à la fois être à proximité
d'habitation et en même temps d'ouvrir
au grand public c'est une vraie gageure
et je pense que c'est une vraie réussite
et 50 ans Yvelines pour cela
historiquement et probablement et à
cette chance là d'être très doté en
matière de collaborateurs une
collaboratrice qui sont capables
d'anticiper des aménagements de haute
valeur à la fois urbanistique et très
vert et donc on rappelle le calendrier
donc très prochainement livraison de
cette piste olympique un Test Event qui
aura lieu à l'automne 2023 cette année
sur cette colline Élancourt et ensuite
de nouveaux aménagements en vue des JO
suivi de la phase d'héritage donc qui va
se dérouler d'octobre 2024 vous disiez
objectif d'ouvrir à la rentrée 2025 pour
ces aménagements
héritage et donc l'engouement on le
disait qui monte autour de ces Jeux
Olympiques il y a d'autres échéances
bien sûr qui vont arriver sur le
territoire de 50 ans de vie nous on a
suivi très dernièrement la tournée des
sites olympiques qui était passé par le
vélodrome le Golf National là c'est
passé par le stade de BMX il y a des
événements forcément qui vont jalonner
l'année là jusqu'à jusqu'à cet échange
olympique très prochainement la journée
olympique je crois olympique
effectivement qui va avoir lieu au mois
de juin mais qui est très importante et
qui reste un événement j'allais dire
récurrent maintenant sur le territoire
ça a commencé avant les Jeux Olympiques
ça continuera bien entendu après puis
faites à nous à votre mouchoir le 23
juillet 2023 départ de la dernière
épreuve du Tour de France qui partira
tout à côté du siège et TV 78 depuis le
vélo de Rome national je pense que c'est
un grand moment on est très heureux
d'accueillir le Tour de France on aura
le Paris-Nice l'année prochaine on a qui
lui également partira du territoire et
traversent le territoire on a luci track
Champion League alors ça peut paraître
vraiment un petit peu barbare mais c'est
en fait la Coupe du monde de cyclisme
sur qui a été revisité et donc il y aura
lieu au mois de novembre et puis le 28
et 29 juillet 2024 avec les épreuves je
cite le VTT puisque on parlait de la
colline d'Élancourt et donc le VTT
qu'ils auront ces épreuves fin juillet
sur la colline d'Élancourt Philippe
femme forcément les champs olympiques
vous l'attendez avec grande impatience
peut-être pour le basket mais pour le
sportif que vous êtes en général
d'autant plus que quand on accueille les
Jeux Olympiques c'est une chance
importante de pouvoir afficher d'une
part qualifier l'ensemble de ces équipes
nationales mais également de travailler
en vue de je dirais d'obtenir des
médailles et les meilleurs résultats
pour autant le sport est ce qu'il est et
je dirais c'est le plus fort qui gagnera
mais pour autant il est vrai que
bénéficier de de sites en France et
avoir une préparation de quatre années
ça permet d'envisager vivement de bons
résultats pour la France je crois que
les premiers matchs auront lieu du côté
de Lille et après ça viendra seulement
sur sur Paris est-ce que tu ne peux pas
être fait sur la région parisienne dans
la mesure où il n'y a pas suffisamment
de je dirais d'endroit qui
le voir sur les sur les images il y
avait des représentants du conseil
municipal des enfants des adolescents du
conseil municipal des jeunes ou encore
des jeunes ambassadeurs des Mureaux tous
ont pu poser des questions et parler de
leur expérience à la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale Yaël brune Pivet
accompagné du maire de la ville François
garer et du préfet légalité des chances
des Yvelines Pascal courtad on écoute la
réaction de Yaël brun Pivet après les
échanges qu'il faut se dire que ces
porteurs d'espoir parce qu'on a des
jeunes qui ont envie de s'engager et on
voit que lorsqu'une ville s'implique
autour de cela ça marche et c'est il se
passe des choses et on voit bien qu'au
bureau il se passe des choses ils aiment
leur ville ils ont envie d'être utile
ils ont envie de faire en sorte que les
choses aillent mieux ils ont envie de
s'impliquer de s'engager et donc c'est
ça qui est le plus frappant
Céline vous est mentionné plusieurs
conseils destinés à la jeunesse aux
Mureaux l'engagement de la commune
semble important dans cette commune des
mureaux justement sur la citoyenneté
effectivement Grégory plusieurs
instances représentatives en fonction
des âges il y a 43 jeunes élus au sein
du conseil municipal des enfants
issus des classes de CM1 et de CM2 des
écoles de la ville le conseil municipal
des jeunes est composé de 30 élus âgés
de 11 à 18 ans puis un dispositif créé
en 2022 à titre expérimental les jeunes
ambassadeurs 24 jeunes lycéens qui
suivent un programme de formation à la
citoyenneté tous ces jeunes contribuent
au développement de projets pour leur
ville on les écoute c'est changer les
mentalités c'est changer aussi on peut
changer notre notre ville et on est à
l'écoute des autres enfants de notre âge
ceux qui ont besoin d'un truc on peut
faire passer le message c'est nous on
est les messagers des élèves en fait
c'est s'intéresser à tout ce qui fait
partie de sa ville de d'où on vient et
de tout ce qui est en dehors aussi de
d'être intéressé à un peu tout tout ce
qui pourrait rapporter à sa ville et aux
habitants
merci Céline pour toutes ces précisions
la jeunesse justement qui était au coeur
de cette première journée de
sensibilisation pour les collégiens écho
déléguer le département des Yvelines
organisés à cet événement il y a
quelques jours à Versailles le principe
des délégués transmettre des éco-gestes
à leur camarade et porter également des
projets écologiques dans leur école on
regarde tout de suite le reportage de
Julien Leroy toute seule réponse
une journée ludique pour sensibiliser au
développement durable c'est l'expérience
vécue par ces 320 collégiens et co
délégués yvelinois au domaine de Madame
Elisabeth à Versailles depuis la rentrée
2020 chaque classe des établissements
secondaires doit posséder un de ses
ambassadeurs son rôle formé ses
camarades aux éco-gestes et porter des
initiatives environnementales ce qu'on
fait c'est que du coup on fait des
réunions et on essaye de
préparer des projets pour l'avenir pour
éviter un max
de gaspillage ou polluer les gestes du
quotidien par l'évolution de ces modes
de consommation il faut se préparer à
lutter contre ce réchauffement contre ce
dérèglement climatique et parce qu'il
entraîne en fait un risque immense pour
l'humanité puis sur l'environnement
atelier sur le tri sélectif ou encore
l'impact du textile sur la planète ce
vendredi 12 mai une trentaine de stands
était présent pour permettre aux égodes
de développer leur connaissance
d'économiser l'énergie qu'on a créé un
jeu
sur la consommation électrique des
appareils donc les élèves doivent
classer c'est comme un jeu timeline
doivent classer de les appareils d'entre
ceux qui se consomment le mois à ceux
qui consomment le plus on a appris qu'il
y a les anciennes ampoules qui
chauffaient beaucoup et que c'est mieux
d'utiliser des LED conservatrice lors de
cette première journée organisée par le
Département 4 collèges ont été
récompensés pour soutenir les projets
des échos délégués 1000 euros et le don
d'un arbre ont été remis aux
établissements
à Versailles toujours un parfum de
Fashion Week flottait dans les rues de
la ville dimanche pour la première fois
l'établissement l'hôtel de ville même
très précisément à accueillir un défilé
de mode éco-responsable et inclusif et
devant plus de 400 personnes Gabriel
Gontier a pu y assister
l'effervescence et l'agitation des
grands jours pour la première fois de
son histoire l'Hôtel de Ville de
Versailles se transforme en podium pour
un défilé de mode éco-responsable une
première également pour une partie des
mannequins et des créateurs pour qu'il
les dernières secondes avant le défilé
sont intenses
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on se créateur de bijoux d'accessoires
ou encore de vêtements au style variés
s'apprête à présenter leur création
devant plus de 400 personnes leur point
commun des pièces engagées pour limiter
l'impact de la mode sur l'environnement
moi mon parti pris c'est plutôt des
matières premières qui sont qui sont qui
viennent de fournisseurs qui a un peu de
autour de Paris en tout cas proche j'ai
tout ce qui est boucleries c'est des
artisans qui fabriquent la boucle le riz
sur Paris c'est plutôt un côté
responsable au niveau de la proximité
des matières et après la fabrication
l'objectif c'est de faire des sacs qui
durent dans le temps sur le travail bois
et cuir il y a deux on a j'ai deux types
de sacs j'ai ce modèle là ça c'est
l'insolent qui a un sac qui est assemblé
par un système de pliage un peu comme
une origami avec du boulot sur le côté
dans une idée très épurée et à l'inverse
on peut aller vers un sac comme ça qui
est réalisé entièrement avec des
coutures faites à la main c'est des
coutures sellier traditionnelles de
maroquinerie qui sont faites à travers
le bois la chef d'orchestre de ce
défiler Alison Laurent créatrice de la
marque Kentucky RA in premier tableau
vous avancez dans le couloir jusqu'à
l'autre porte c'est parti pour une
demi-heure de chaude un défilé atypique
mêlant danse et musique un défilé
doublement engagé car en plus d'être
écologique les créateurs ont choisi
l'inclusivité dans le choix des
mannequins
[Musique]
parmi les mannequins justement Cindy
fontaine une créatrice de bijoux
éco-responsable pour qu'il est important
de créer avec des matières déjà
existantes c'est hyper important parce
que de toute façon il y a tellement de
matières premières finalement il y a pas
besoin d'aller repeint à chaque fois des
matières premières tous ces bijoux
fantaisie qui sont cassés et qui dorment
dans justement nos tiroirs et dont on y
n'a plus aucune utilité nous on s'amuse
justement on faire des nouveaux bijoux
et qui plaisent encore donc pourquoi ne
pas continuer comme ça c'est hyper
important de réutiliser de réemployer
les matières premières le but de ce
défiler également sensibiliser le public
à l'évolution de l'industrie de la mode
vers plus de durabilité super beau une
super organisation les vêtements étaient
bien diverses enfin divers très joli
très bien mis en valeur par les
mannequins bah moi j'ai trouvé très
intéressant il y avait un rythme on
voyait bien les univers des différents
créateurs Paris réussi pour les
créateurs accueillis par le public sous
un tonnerre d'applaudissements
turn over dans le 7 8 avec Véronique
Iturbide qui nous a rejoint au plateau
bonsoir Véronique comme d'habitude vous
venez pour vos insolites ces
informations originales qui ont
peut-être échappé à nos téléspectateurs
la semaine dernière où nous parliez
justement de ce défiler éco-responsable
qui s'est déroulée Versailles là ce soir
quel est le menu alors le menu je vous
emmener prendre l'air dans des parcours
comestibles après on va parler de quatre
yoga et après on va parler encore dans
la forêt encore dans l'eau Bonnaire des
de faim les naissances de fans et après
je pourrais peut-être faire ma pub pour
les VIP pour les présentez un grand
talent sur TV 78 dans un instant et bien
on va parler d'abord et reparler de
sport et de cet événement qui va
peut-être attirer attirer les regards
au-delà des seuls fans de basket et de
NBA la loterie de la draft NBA se tient
cette nuit aux États-Unis aux alentours
de 2 heures du matin on connaîtra à
l'issue de ce rendez-vous l'équipe qui
aura le choix numéro 1 pour recruter en
vue de la saison prochaine dans le
prestigieux championnat de basket nord
américain et donc par la même occasion
on connaîtra la franchise qui devrait
enrôler livlinois Victor web bagnama qui
est annoncé comme le numéro 1 de cette
draft 2023 le joueur de 19 ans 2 mètres
21 a débuté le basket au club de
l'Entente le chêne et Versailles dans
les Yvelines où il a évolué entre 2011
et 2014 Philippe femme vous êtes
toujours avec nous président de l'ELCV
78 déjà de voir Victor webmanyama sur le
devant de la scène pure produit Illinois
même si on l'a dit il a fait le gros de
sa formation après à Nanterre dans les
Hauts-de-Seine qu'est-ce que ça vous
fait ça c'est une fierté en tant que
président de le LCV 78 de voir Paris
parcours dans le basket alors moi je
pense que c'est pas une fierté pour le
club de duchane Versailles c'est une
fierté pour la France parce qu'en
réalité comme je dis tout à l'heure il
s'agit d'un prodige c'est c'est
quelqu'un qui a un niveau exceptionnel
de par sa taille de par sa vélocité de
par sa technicité de par son mental il
réunit toutes les qualités d'un très
très grand et c'est vrai qu'en France
même si on a eu de très très bons
basketteurs qui ont évolué au plus haut
niveau de la NBA c'est bien la première
fois que nous avons effectivement un
jeune français de 19 ans rappelant le
qui est capable non seulement de
rivaliser avec les joueurs américains
qui journée université qui font partie
de la draft mais qui situe devant et et
bien au-delà on faisait parler de cela
et Kylian Mbappé il est tout à fait
justifié ce parallèle qui vient de bater
avec le football Victor web benjama
c'est le MP du basket oui en sachant que
entre le football et le basket bon ce
sont deux sports collectifs mais
évidemment il y a beaucoup de différence
pour autant ce sont deux ce sont deux
météorites qui qui sont arrivés sur la
sur la terre et et dans le sport
français et c'est une chance pour la
France alors pour expliquer réexpliquer
même la loterie de la draft NBA qui est
somme toute assez compliqué pour les
initier il y a 14 franchises de NBA qui
participent il s'agit de celles qui ne
se sont pas qualifiées pour les playoffs
c'est à dire les phases finales de la
NBA se sont elles qui auront les
premiers choix de recrutement des
meilleures espoirs pour la saison
prochaine et pour déterminer l'ordre des
équipes qui ont ces premiers choix une
loterie avec des balles de ping-pong qui
sont tirées le tout sous les yeux d'un
huissier de justice pour les pires
franchises de la saison celles qui ont
terminé le plus bas dans le classement
le pourcentage de chance d'être tiré en
sort en premier et plus élevé alors
parmi les équipes qui ont justement le
plus de probabilité de décrocher ce
ticket d'or pour choisir en premier on
retrouve les Détroit pistons les Houston
Rocket ou encore les Sand Antonio sports
par lesquels sont passés bien sûr
incertain Tony Parker 14% de chance les
Charlotte Hornet eux ont 12,5% de
chances on peut citer également les
Blazers de Portland avec
10,5% et donc l'équipe qui est tirée en
première pourra donc choisir en premier
le joueur qu'elle souhaite recruter lors
de la draft qui se tiendra elle le 22
juin prochain et sauf grande surprise il
s'agira donc de l'équipe qui va
normalement rouler Victor wenbanyama
puisqu'on rappelle que le français est
annoncé comme le numéro 1 de cette draft
2023 est-ce qu'il y a une préférence
pour vous pour voir évoluer Victor la
saison prochaine en NBA il y en a
beaucoup alors on avait pas posé la
question à nos chroniqueurs de si on
parlait sport il le voit forcément dans
les Spurs parce que Tony Parker un autre
prodige français est passé mais en
réalité c'est plutôt Victor qu'il
faudrait poser la question car nous qui
sommes très très loin de de la draft
bien sûr
les Spurs de son Antonio ont accueilli
de nombreux Français ils ont accueilli
Tony Parker qui est une idole et qui est
homophem le premier Français holophobe
au niveau américain ça aussi c'est à
souligner parce que c'est c'est très
rare effectivement pour un étranger
d'atteindre ce niveau là et et et pour
autant c'est vrai que les sports sont
une formation qui permet à des jeunes
comme vict certainement de continuer à
progresser alors qu'il y a d'autres
équipes bon qui vont tout de suite à
vouloir aller chercher le résultat et et
forcément de ce fait à la progression
risque d'être un petit peu freiné parce
que quand on met en avant le résultat
par rapport à la formation forcément il
faut accélérer les choses mais bon pour
autant je pense que quel que soit le
choix Victor sera satisfait vous ayez
tout à l'heure vous allez suivre cette
draft j'imagine c'est la même chose pour
les joueurs de l'ELCV 78 les joueuses et
les joueurs il y a un engouement au club
alors il y a un engouement mais c'est
vrai pour tout le basket français en
réalité je crois que c'est un événement
français c'est pas un événement local
même si effectivement Victor est issu
des Yvelines et des dix clubs du chêne
et Versailles en réalité c'est une
fierté pour la France de d'avoir un
joueur de ce niveau qui participe à
cette loterie alors c'est une loterie on
connaît les vainqueurs très tôt
ce n'est pas comme Loterie Nationale où
on connaît le gagnant du gros lot
parfois même qui ne se fait pas
connaître lui donc Victor lui va suivre
cette loterie à Paris indirectement dans
un endroit qui est tenu secret à
entourer de ses coéquipiers staff aussi
à des médecins 92 de Boulogne Levallois
des agents ses amis aussi bien sûr de sa
famille un lieu tenu secret je le disais
mais il a folle toute la sphère du
basket basket français même au-delà de
de l'Atlantique quel regard vous portez
sur cette ascension fulgurante nous nous
avait dit tout à l'heure que vous aviez
un regard voilà plutôt
positive bien sûr presque impressionné
sur sur cette progression fulgurante oui
mais on a quand même l'impression qu'il
garde la tête sur les épaules Victor web
benyama malgré toute la hype tout toute
les performances qu'on lui prête oui
c'est étonnant de le voir d'ailleurs on
le voit bien dans les rencontres qui
sont diffusées à la télévision puisque
c'est une attraction Victor bagnola il
remplit l'accord Arena de 15000
personnes en réalité bien sûr il y a
tous les pros qui l'accompagnent mais
mais c'est quand même lui qui
aujourd'hui draine tous ces spectateurs
il y a plus qu'un engouement enfin c'est
quelque chose de c'est une folie pour
autant
moi je trouve qu'il a la tête sur les
épaules on le voit bien même sur le
terrain c'est déjà leader à 19 ans il
amène autour de lui je dirais l'équipe
il est posé et donc c'est certainement
quelqu'un qui va encore progresser à la
fois mentalement physiquement et dans la
technicité et dans son rôle de leader
même s'il est passé très brièvement par
le club de 2011 2014 tout de même trois
ans quel souvenir vous gardez de lui
on garde on garde de lui le fait que
s'il était très très grand déjà puisque
il dominait tout le monde de plus d'une
tête il jouait déjà il était surclassé
comme parce qu'il est arrivé en baby
baby basket c'est à dire dans tout
premier niveau de notre économie basket
je dois saluer aussi les leurs ses
parents Elodie et Félix qui ont été
longtemps éducateurs sportifs chez nous
et d'ailleurs qui au départ de ces
premiers pas dans le dans le basket
l'ont accompagné aussi dans notre école
de mini basket mais mais c'est quelqu'un
déjà dont on savait qu'il aurait un
avenir pour autant en imaginait pas
qu'il aurait 7 à venir là parce que il a
su se former profiter de tout ce qu'il a
appris et il avait des qualités innées
qui évidemment lui ont permis de d'aller
au-delà de tout ce qu'on pouvait
imaginer former ensuite à Nanterre où il
a débuté en ProA il a aussi évolué à
l'ASVEL durant une saison dont le
président est Tony Parker puis cette
saison au mètre 92 du sélectionneur
français Vincent Collet a eu aussi ses
premières en équipe de France sélection
aussi au sein de l'équipe All Stars de
la LNB on a quand même l'impression que
même si vous disiez c'est un prodige là
il y avait une vraie progression sur
cette dernière saison de Pro A oui en
fait il a gravé beaucoup d'échelons dans
sa formation dans les différents clubs
pro il est passé mais il a pris une
vraie dimension cette saison mais ça
c'est le capital qu'il engrangé depuis
que il a commencé à faire du basket et
il est je dirais extrêmement présent
à tous niveaux au niveau du nombre de
points au niveau de la
sa teneur sur le terrain en terme
psychologique par rapport à l'équipe il
est vraiment aujourd'hui
plein de qualité qui à mon avis vont
encore progresser parce que aux
États-Unis il va se frotter à un
environnement encore plus compétitif et
il va falloir qu'il à la fois qu'ils se
renforce physiquement parce que à 19 ans
il est encore frais mais les Américains
savent effectivement faire progresser
tout en faisant attention à la santé et
puis il va en continuer à progresser
techniquement
ça devrait être l'arme fatale pour les
équipes qui vont l'avoir dans leur dans
leur rang dans la mesure où Vitor est un
très grand gabarit dont on pourrait
penser qu'il va jouer dessous c'est à
dire sous le panier or en réalité sa
force c'est de s'éloigner du panier et à
2 mètres 21 si vous tirez si vous tirez
à 4 5 6 ou 8 m il est impossible d'aller
chercher donc je pense que les équipes
qui vont
l'accueillir vont travailler
cette disposition là parce que comme je
le disais instance c'est l'arme fatale
qu'aucun club ne connaît aujourd'hui et
la loterie de cette draft NBA se tient
donc cette nuit aux alentours de 2
heures du matin on reviendra sur les
résultats de la loterie demain avec
notre consultant basket Mike mocongo
merci Philippe femme en tout cas d'être
venu à en parler en plateau je rappelle
que vous êtes le président de l'Entente
le Chenet Versailles 78 clubs dans
lequel a effectué ses débuts Victor
webmail merci d'avoir été avec nous à
présent la traversée de l'écoquartier du
parc du lac sur une corde tendue entre
deux grues le tout suspendu à 40 mètres
du sol le funambule Lukas Giovanni
Moreira a délivré cette performance le
week-end dernier à cette occasion les
promoteurs du Grand Paris 50 ans en
Yvelines et ils vont organiser un
événement pour le grand public où on
pouvait tester ces talons
d'équilibrissent le reportage et de
Régine ralech et de Julien Leroy
[Musique]
traverser une Highline en plein chantier
un scénario peu probable et pourtant
cette performance a bien vu le jour ce
weekend à Voisins-le-Bretonneux
[Musique]
pour initier des visiteurs à la
slackline une expérience loin d'être
anodine pour de nombreux visiteurs
c'était très dur fallait être précis
il fallait avoir beaucoup d'équilibre je
pense que ça n'a absolument rien à voir
avec ce que Lucas a pu ressentir là-haut
mais bon c'est c'est amusant et c'est
assez grisant de de trouver aussi cette
équilibre sur en fait sur une ligne qui
qui n'est pas stable ces animations ont
été proposées au sein de l'écoquartier
du parc du lac actuellement en
construction le but faire découvrir ce
nouvel espace de la ville pensée pour
répondre aux enjeux actuels de
développement durable et de transition
énergétique c'est l'avantage c'est
d'abord de proposer une animation
sympathique pour les habitants et puis
en plus de leur faire découvrir le
quartier parce qu'on voit que là les les
personnes se promènent dans le dans le
quartier découvre les différents espaces
parce que il est quand même assez vaste
il y a 10 hectares un écho quartier dont
la livraison est prévue pour 2024
allez les insolites de Véronique c'est
tout de suite dans le 7 8
et on commence Véronique par des
parcours à découvrir du côté de manier
les hameaux chose étonnante s'ils sont
comestibles
prendre l'air et cueillir soit des baies
soit des fleurs soit des feuilles soit
des fruits voilà c'est une association
qui s'appelle manier en transition qui a
fait ça emporter en arrière avec la
ville de Magny-les-Hameaux et qui vous
propose trois parcours
différents bien sûr avec plusieurs une
longueur différente vous en avez un qui
est de 3 km qui s'appelle la boucle
urbaine qui est accessible à tout le
monde même si on est à mobilité réduite
vous en avez un autre s'appelle la
boucle de la vallée qui qui a 10 km et
la boucle des hameaux qui lui fait 14 km
alors c'est entretenu par les jardiniers
municipaux de Magny-les-Hameaux en fait
autrefois il y avait déjà il y avait des
beaucoup de poiriers beaucoup de
pommiers et la population se servait que
hier faisait même du site etc donc ils
sont un peu voulu retrouver cette idée
là donc ils planter une 150 arbres et
150 arbustes fruitiers voilà et c'est
complètement gratuit et ce sont des
parcours qu'on fait donc voilà seul il y
a des panneaux pédagogiques en revanche
qui vous explique quand il y a les
choses quoi en faire etc alors sortie
aussi éducation parce qu'on peut
apprendre et vous commencez on vous fera
remarquer remarquer on vous fera
découvrir des arbres remarquables sur un
des parcours aussi voilà c'est un
patrimoine à la fois naturel et culturel
parce qu'il y a aussi des des
lieux partout enfin des lieux à
découvrir voilà alors par exemple sachez
qu'en ce moment c'est bien de cueillir
les orties parce qu'elles ont leur plus
haute teneurs en fer et alors du coup
vous allez parce que c'est pas le tout
cueillir des orties des fleurs d'acacia
ou des fleurs de pissenlit il faut
savoir quoi en faire et il vous donne
des recettes alors moi je les ai vu sur
le site peut-être que c'est sur les
panneaux j'en sais rien mais c'est
facile vous pouvez alors un pesto
d'ortie par exemple facile à souffler
d'orties alimentales vous qui aimez
l'Italie je vous recommande une panna
cotta à la fleur d'acacia très facile à
faire la cotta il faut le savoir et
quelque chose encore plus drôle rigolo
c'est un comment ça s'appelle pardon
j'arrive une fricassée de pédoncule de
pissenlit donc vous voyez le pissenlit
jaune bon après ils sont plus jaunes il
y a des petites chandelles qu'on s'amuse
à souffler vous faites ça vous aussi
je le fais plus mais ça m'est déjà
arrivé parce que ça se mange pas ça donc
vous soufflez bien sur vos fleurs après
vous éliminer les capit sont les boutons
des des pissenlits et après vous faites
votre votre fricassée enfin tout est
bien expliqué voilà donc on peut
découvrir plein de choses et aussi des
des recettes gustatives les déguster on
nous parle en vous vous faites découvrir
je vais y arriver pardon à Véronique du
yoga mais du yoga original puisqu'il est
à pratiquer avec des chats ça s'appelle
le catchua voilà alors le yoga c'est
tendance le catch yoga ou le pet yoga
c'est encore plus tendance ça vient de
sortir apparemment ça vient des
États-Unis donc là ça s'est passé à
Maurepas dans le centre aquatique
castellia il y a eu deux séances de yoga
avec en présence de 10 chatons alors
c'est un initiative aussi d'une
association l'association sauvetage et
chat en détresse qui a une antenne en
Île-de-France et l'idée c'était aussi de
que ça fasse levier pour que les gens
aient envie d'adopter un chat
éventuellement mais pas que ça c'est
aussi ça fait penser à la remontée un
chat qui vient se poser sur vous vendre
quand vous êtes en pleine méditation et
ça apaise et aux États-Unis il y a même
des gens qui le font avec des chats des
chèvres naines des lapins enfin un
animal de compagnie quoi
au centre aquatique castelia
bientôt de nouvelles sessions de de
catchuya du côté de Maurepas et on va
terminer en forêt de Rambouillet ou les
fonds sont très vulnérables puisqu'en ce
moment c'est la période des naissances
voilà ça faisait longtemps qu'on avait
pas parlé des fonds alors là c'est la
période des naissances comme vous dites
alors ce qu'il faut faire c'est surtout
si vous envoyez si vous en croisez un
enfant caché dans les airs il faut
surtout pas s'en approcher même si la
mère est pas là ça veut pas dire qu'il a
abandonné au contraire elle est partie
la chevrette est partie se nourrir pour
pouvoir allaiter son bébé parce qu'elle
a besoin de reconstituer ses forces il
se peut aussi qu'elle ait eu deux fonds
et les naissances en fait se font pas
coup sur coup il y a plusieurs heures
d'intervalle entre la naissance du
premier du second fond et elle est elle
accouche pas au même endroit je pense
que c'est l'idée c'est de pas mettre
tous ses œufs dans le même panier donc
donc elle est entre les deux quand elle
en a deux donc voilà on peut croire que
que le fond est abandonné par sa maman
et pas du tout il faut surtout pas y
toucher et surtout surtout tenir ses
chiens son chien en laisse car pareil
l'odeur du chien après la chevrette ne
s'occupe plus du bébé qui est
extrêmement vulnérable pendant un mois
et même jusqu'à 6 mois et puis le chien
peut blesser aussi le fond et donc voilà
voilà
surtout surtout pas y toucher merci
Véronique et je le disais on vous
retrouve aussi très régulièrement la
présentation de Vy P veri Yvelines qui
mettent en lumière les personnalités du
département qui sont vos prochains
invités alors merci de me souligner
c'est gentil voilà alors j'ai invité
Mathieu Davignac et directeur de
recherche au château de Versailles c'est
un historien auteur et qui est aussi
conseillé pour le cinéma assez souvent
d'ailleurs et là il vient de sortir un
livre qui s'appelle le plaisir de vivre
ou les libertés de la marquise de Joco
c'est à dire et c'est une histoire d'une
jeune femme très libre qui qui se marie
qui divorce qu'un enfant naturel qui
épouse son amant c'était aussi la
maîtresse de Talleyrand et c'est une
période un peu un peu charnière juste
après la Révolution et il y a plein de
liberté qui après malheureusement
seront supprimés mais elle en a profité
et elle a bien fait voilà et deuxième
émission c'était avec Eric Jansen qui
est le co-auteur de très cher baron de
Rothschild avec Nadine de Rothschild la
fameuse baronne elle relate la vie de 12
baronnes de Rothschild voilà et des
femmes assez incroyables une à la
passion des bateaux de course l'autre
consacre la vie à l'étude des puces et
donc des v YP à retrouver dès à présent
on dit le signal dans l'oreillette c'est
déjà disponible sur Youtube vous avez
aussi sur TV 78.com pour retrouver Vy P
bien sûr votre émission sur TV 78 on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine
pour de nouveaux insolites merci merci à
vous
on va tester d'ici là samedi dernier
c'était la Nuit européenne des musées le
musée de la ville de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et la
médiathèque du canal à Montigny le
Bretonneux ce sont justement associés
pour une soirée sur le thème de l'espace
de nombreux animations et activités
étaient au programme réalité virtuelle
simulation de vol ou encore et
démonstration de sabre laser près de
1000 personnes ont participé à
l'événement on écoute les réactions au
micro de Julien Leroy c'est un des
grands temps forts de notre de notre
programmation donc on met tous les ans
le deuxième week-end de mai et à cette
occasion on fait toujours une soirée
comme ça en général de qui se termine
vers 23 h ou minuit c'est un super
spectacle ça permet de faire vivre le
quartier et puis il y avait des
acrobates il y avait des artifices il y
avait des personnes déguisées donc
c'était très colorés très vivant et très
très bien ça attire des jeunes ça attire
des un peu tout le monde oui c'est très
important d'avoir la culture au moins de
Montigny et il faut il faudrait encore
plus je pense mais déjà c'est pas mal ce
qu'ils font
et puis direction Saint-Germain-en-Laye
pour la fin de ce 7 8 ou un marché
européen se tenait à samedi dernier
l'occasion de fêter l'Europe et de
sensibiliser informer également les
visiteurs sur les actions de lieu
explications avec Martin Patry de nos
confrères de radio sensation
[Musique]
festive qui anime les rues de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye quelques jours
après la journée de l'Europe je suis sur
la place du Marché Neuf qui se tient
toute la journée la 17e édition du
marché européen un événement organisé
par la ville de Saint-Germain-en-Laye
avec l'aide de la Maison de l'Europe des
Yvelines
le marché européen c'est de pouvoir
montrer un petit peu à nos concitoyens
au saint-germain-nois et à toute la
région un petit peu ce qu'est l'Europe
ce que propose l'Europe aussi bien sur
le plan que culinaire puisque nous avons
beaucoup de stands culinaires mais
également sur le plan comment dirais-je
culturel nous avons cinq jumelages donc
quatre en Europe donc vraiment le marché
européen c'est de montrer et de prouver
à nos si toi à nos concitoyens que
l'Europe est au cœur de notre vie
[Musique]
parmi tous les stands du marché on
retrouve évidemment des stands
d'information notamment celui de la
Maison de l'Europe des Yvelines dont la
mission est de rapprocher les citoyens
de l'Union européenne pourquoi ce marché
européen est-il important en quoi c'est
important de mettre en valeur cette
culture européenne
mutuelle en tant que européen à travers
notre histoire commune en tant que
européen nous pouvons tous chacun
œuvrer à nos échelles différentes pour
la paix la Concorde européenne et nous
permettre en réalité de d'avoir un
continent plus fort dans ce contexte
global qui est de plus en plus anxiogène
pour beaucoup de nos concitoyens bon il
est maintenant 12h30 l'heure d'aller
manger un morceau ça tombe bien
aujourd'hui des dizaines de commerçants
proposent des spécialités culinaires de
toute l'Europe spécialité roumaines
suédoise espagnole ou encore belge les
visiteurs n'ont que l'embarras du choix
c'est quoi les spécialités culinaires de
la Belgique aujourd'hui on a ramené on a
fait des moules frites et on a aussi
ramené de la carbonade flamande ce qui
est c'est comme un bœuf Bourguignon mais
cuit à la bière et du coup c'est fait
avec une bière brune et c'est la recette
de mon arrière-grand-mère
[Musique]
des sourires du soleil et de la musique
pour les organisateurs la 17e édition du
marché européen est une grande réussite
moi je vous laisse je vais aller goûter
cette fameuse carbonade flamande
avant de vous laisser dernier point sur
les prévisions météo de demain
[Musique]
conditions similaire à celle
d'aujourd'hui dans la matinée de
mercredi du soleil à prévoir dans les
Yvelines qu'on te dit degrés dans toute
la moitié est du département 9 degrés
dans le secteur de ou dans l'après-midi
le ciel devrait se couvrir mais les
températures remontent il fera 16 degrés
à Mantes-la-Jolie Houdan et Rambouillet
15 degrés dans le secteur de Versailles
voilà c'est la fin de ce 7 8 merci de
nous avoir suivis nouvel édition demain
même heure et c'est avec Mathilde Franco
à la présentation belle soirée sur TV 78
[Musique]